So let's see how performance is affected by the number of cores. Suppose we take
a single-core execution and we break down the time in it, according to how much
available parallelism there would be. So for 20% of the time, we
really can only run on one core. For 30% of the time, we
could use two cores if we had them. For 40% of the time, we could
use three cores if we had them. And for 10% of the time, we can use four cores
if we had them. Now suppose that we have a chip whose total power is 100 watts.
If that power is enough to get five gigahertz
if the chip only has one core, then how
many gigahertz can we get when we have two
cores, and how many gigahertz when we have four
cores on the chip? Also if our execution time is 100 seconds for a
one-core chip, it will be how many seconds for a two-core chip,
and how many seconds for a four-core chip? Keep in mind that you
need to take into account the change in frequency for this as well.